you kind of was giving the little kids
in the sandbox aside I like bro you bed
and I'll eat a toy cuz it might not be
there when you get back today we are
here to try McDonald's Happy Meals for
the very first time when I was little my
parents never really took me to a lot of
fast food restaurants I don't know what
to expect home game from Happy Meal I
know what the food tastes like now I've
had McDonald's will it taste a little
sweeter I feel like I'm getting a gift I
had a choice of apple juice milk or
chocolate milk I love chocolate milk it
is my favorite drink of all time should
I wait til I eat to open the toy that's
like there's always like a loose food
like a fry you know we always get the
loose ones at the bottom of the bag to
get in a cup like this is great oh it's
like 3d kind of trippy oh this is a
transformer toys I don't know if I
should be starting with this good so all
this is a cup with a sticker I can go to
Legoland kids can go free okay cool I
don't have any kids look at that that
looks great life is so simple is come
home to a little homework that is
happening a bit as if you're watching
cartoons
I use my toy which again now this
defeats the purpose of calling it a toy
my favorite should be pissed fish on me
eating this but it's good and I'm gonna
eat the whole thing this is like the
cutest little fry ever look at the head
in the palm of my hand I'm just gonna
down these fries is this is easier hmm
I'm more entreated this man and his
stupid cup
I love this soggy fries one was just hot
there's got a nice crunch - salt - salt
ratio we're good either so cute so
smooth it's nice that they cut it out
like this my mom used to cut apples like
this so it was easy to eat all you
wanted was the happy meal because it had
a cool toy where there's like a Disney
Princess or a Hot Wheel
I didn't cup I'm really sorry this is
not a toy it might just sound like a
whiny jerk right now I'm feel like to
this day this would still get the job
down it taught us portion control they
really had to see the success well this
has been a great experience I would eat
it again and again and again and it
would have eaten it so many times more
if I could have as kid I never read
nutrition
who can read that
[Music]